[Music]
all right hi everyone welcome my name is
Mary Puccini I'm a product manager on
data studio and I'm Riccardo Muti I'm a
product manager as well we're excited to
be here today so we have a pretty full
session for you so we'll just go ahead
and jump right in first things first
let's start with questions so we will
have time at the end for questions you
probably have seen this slide in some of
your breakouts but if you're not aware
there's a Dory link in the app we also
will have live questions as well so feel
free to make use of both we're excited
to hear your questions at the end okay
so we have about 40 minutes of content
for you and the concerts really
structured around common problems that
many of you have faced when you're using
VI tools and really trying to get data
out to your colleagues you all can make
better decisions so to start us off
we're gonna do a little warm-up it's the
end of day two on this wonderful
conference so I'm gonna do a little
audience participation just all you have
to do is raise your hand it's pretty
minimal so I'm gonna ask you a question
raise your hand if this resonates let's
see here so raise your hand if you have
started running a query started taking a
little bit of time so you got distracted
you went to go check your email and you
never came back alright personally it
definitely happened okay another one for
you raise your hand if you get asked to
write a sequel query for a colleague on
a regular basis laughter resonates with
us okay last but not least not data
studio not Google cloud related San
Francisco related how many of you have
visited San Francisco in the summer and
frozen yes I'm a resident and I still
get caught off guard so as I said we're
excited to be here today we have about
the next 45 minutes with you all we'll
spend the majority of a non-event on
talking about these kind of common
problems and then actually going through
the real solutions that you can start
using today we have lots of demos
planned for you so I hope you guys are
excited we'll spend a little bit of time
talking about some of the new features
and a lot of these are interspersed
throughout our content
today so you'll be seen a lot of stuff
that's brand new as of today and then as
I said we'll have time for Q&A at the
end okay so to set the stage many of you
have experienced a lot of these
challenges that we're going to talk
through but in this case we're gonna use
a fictional character named Ruth Ruth
works at the FAA and she is somebody who
came to next last year she watched the
data studio and bigquery session and got
really excited about what it could do
for her and her work so she started
using it to distribute data to her teams
and start analyzing data on flight
delays and we're gonna kind of use this
thread throughout of some of these
common challenges that she's seen as
she's progressing in her career one
thing that I would call out is that Ruth
was a victim of her own success she was
able to start using data studio and
bigquery to really start solving some
tough problems and then the emails
started coming in can you get me access
to this data can you help me with this
query and so we're gonna talk about how
we can scale and kind of solve some of
those problems so with that I'm gonna go
ahead and turn it over to Ricardo to
kick us off on analysis thank you Mary
so as Mary mentioned Ruth's became known
as the sequel guru the person who if you
had a business question you could send a
question to her she would know how to
craft the sequel query for you and send
you back your CSV file your spreadsheet
so you could do your analysis but she
quickly became inundated with those
requests so her goal is how can she
empower her colleagues many of whom are
not quite so technical as her not quite
such a sequel guru to self-serve to do
some of their own data analysis but some
of the challenges with that are number
one how do we make data analysis easy
enough for those less technical users
some of them don't know much sequel some
of them don't know any sequel so really
making it easy means making it visual
making it interactive making it natural
and then the other thing that happens if
she'll send somebody a report and
they'll say well can you also add this
column in this column and I need these
two things added together we can't
anticipate every dimension and every
metric that these all these different
users might need and they sometimes
invent their own metrics derived on top
of the data how can we make it possible
for them to enrich the data
do a little bit of this light data
modeling and add their own dimensions
and metrics and calculations and make it
as easy as you know them doing that sort
of thing by writing a formula in in a
spreadsheet for example and last but not
least how do we make that whole
experience just wicked fast like you
know if you're clicking on a column and
a column chart you're clicking on a
slice and a pie chart you know whereas
when you're running a sequel query if
you get a result over terabytes of data
in 10 seconds 15 seconds that's rather
amazing but it's not good enough in this
scenario people are going to be clicking
through things drilling filtering
slicing dicing it needs to be two
seconds one second maybe sub second so
how do we do that so enough talking
about this I'm gonna show you how you
can do it so we already talked about how
Ruth was really the champion for a big
query within the FAA within her
organization within her team she got all
of this flight data landed into bigquery
and from there she's rights or sequel
queries she's super productive she gets
her answers she exports the data she
sends CSV files to people and so on but
if you wanted to go from bigquery to
data studio how exactly do you do that
well it can be as simple as this I just
go from a bigquery table and I go to
export and I say explore in data studio
and it's gonna create the connection for
you set it all up and in a moment here
we'll see a live connection to the
bigquery table and some results that are
coming back and when you when you do
this and you actually save your work one
of the artifacts that gets created is
called a data source
it's what the data studio calls the data
source and it is the proxy for your data
for your bigquery table it's a secure
connection to it it knows how to
authenticate to it you can give all of
your fields friendly human readable
names you can add additional calculated
fields and now if you share this with
your users instead of a CSV file or a
spreadsheet they're one click away from
creating a report on top of this without
worrying about prepping the data or
connecting to the data or just maybe
visually exploring the data and that's
what I'm gonna focus on today you know
data studio has this great tool to be
able to design these really beautiful
reports but right now I don't even know
what report I want I just I'm new to
this data I want to familiarize myself
with it I want to see what's in it what
interesting metrics and trends what are
some different ways of visualizing the
data
and so I want just a really productive
rapid visual exploration experience and
so that's data studio Explorer it's a
different part of data studio that many
people haven't played with yet but it's
getting better and better with every
month that we invest into it and I want
to show you so one of the things I might
do first is I might just have a sort of
metadata question like how large is this
data set how large is this table this
scorecard will aggregate a metric into a
single number and so it automatically
created a record count metric for me
which is the number of rows and so this
is going to aggregate the total number
of rows in the table and just like that
I can see I have a hundred and sixteen
million rows worth of data in this
bigquery table so all of the performance
that you're gonna see is I'm clicking
around drilling slicing filtering is
doing live queries over 116 million rows
worth of data and it's still gonna be
fast so each row represents a flight so
this is a hundred and sixteen million
flights over the last almost 20 years or
so worth of data
another analytic technique that I will
use is looking at the same data in
different ways through different types
of visualizations different types of
charts or in this case maybe a map what
I want to do is I want to look at which
states have the most flights departing
from them which states have the most
departures and just like that it live
queried 116 million rows geocoded the
states based on their name and plotted
them on a map and they're colored in
color intensity by how many state
departures how many departures are from
those states so the most is California
followed closely by Texas that's at the
state level what if I wanted to look at
the city level what are the cities with
the most departures in the United States
for domestic commercial flights
well another analytic technique is to
look at data different ways
simultaneously so I'm not limited to one
chart I can add another chart beside
this and maybe here I want to go add you
know the origin city before I drag that
in what do you think the city is in the
United States with the most departures
for domestic flights anyone want to
venture a guess
la anyone else JFK okay those are good
guesses I drag this in drumroll it's
Chicago there you go
and so I'll just make this whole bit
bigger so we can easily read it top
three Chicago Atlanta
does anyone know why those cities are
special connections they are the largest
hub of the three largest airlines United
Delta and American Airlines respectively
cool so those are the top cities with
departures in the US all right
Ricardo were in the Bay Area can we look
at destinations coming into San
Francisco oh so so we want to look at
the destination in San Francisco and so
okay so what are the top the cities with
the most departures not anywhere but to
San Francisco specifically so it sounds
like we want to filter to San Francisco
and so look how easy that is I can just
go up to my filter shelf here I've got a
field called destination destination
city name I'll pick that I can open this
up and just like that I've got a filter
I can scroll down and find San Francisco
but this is Google so let's Google it so
I'm gonna do San Francisco if I can
spell San Francisco okay and now I don't
need to uncheck everything else I can
just have this handy button here that
says I only want San Francisco and just
like that no sequel nowhere clause and
sub-second response I've filtered 116
million rows the city with the most
departures to San Francisco isn't no
longer is no longer Chicago its LA it's
a lot of people commuting from LA to San
Francisco
these charts aren't just charts they're
not just pretty pictures they are
automatically interactive and we're
making them more and more interactive
every month so one of the things that
we're launching just today is the
ability to quickly sort any chart that
supports starting a chart that supports
sorting to be able to sort it right from
the chart I don't have to go into the
configuration for it I could just say
well if these are the cities with the
most departures to San Francisco what
are the cities with the fewest
departures to San Francisco over the
last 20 years has anyone ever flown from
Lewiston Idaho to San Francisco okay
over the last 20 years there was a grand
total of one flight so if you were on
that flight it was literally a
once-in-a-lifetime experience also
interesting that's catching my eye here
is there were eight flights from San
Jose to San Francisco if you don't know
your Bayer geography that is like 38
miles from here I took an uber Mary does
this commute several times a week I
don't know if you notice that once every
couple of years or so there's a flight
home available let's start looking so
yeah so these are the insights that sort
of we can reveal only by interacting
with the data and just exploring not
only are these charts interactive but
they are automatically linked to each
other I didn't do any special
configuration here but if I want to
filter by California I don't have to
keep defining these filters in the
filter shelf
I'm already plotting something by state
so I could just click on California to
cross filter cities with the most
departures in California in Texas in
Florida and look at the speed that I'm
getting from that how am I getting that
speed so actually it's courtesy of the
bigquery BI engine so there was a
session on this just before this one it
was shown in the keynote as well
this is launching in beta today so
definitely go back and watch those
videos and check this out and learn more
about it all you really need to know
about it is this column store in memory
engine it just makes everything super
fast okay so this is operating on top of
big query BI engine so you might have
recognized that technique that I did
there as sort of a drill down like I'm
drilling down from state to city and
drilling into California and Texas and
Florida and so on it's good if I want
these sort of multi faceted views a map
and a chart but what if I don't want to
consume the space for that I really just
need the one with the ability to
navigate between those two levels of
details state and city so you can now do
that I'm gonna take origin state name
and drag it into this chart into the
hierarchy and now what is this button I
can drill up from city to state so the
top states control back down to top
cities this is drill down and it's
available today in data studio for most
of the basic chart types yeah you can
applaud that why not okay
not only can I drill down but I can
still do that filter drill down that I
did before so I can look at for example
what are the top cities in California
just select California drill down and
those are the top cities in California
pretty cool huh so what if I wanted to
drill down into multiple things like
what if I wanted to drill down into only
the northwest the Pacific Northwest
Oregon and Washington this can be
actually kind of tricky to do in some
tools where you're limited to drill it
down into a single item at a time here I
could do multi select
you'll see the Pacific Northwest
selected in the map and I control down
and see these are the cities with the
most departures in the Pacific Northwest
okay we haven't done any time series
analysis yet so maybe that would be a
good point to introduce that so look at
some trends over time so maybe let me
multi select these and I'm just gonna
make a little bit of room so that I can
do some light rearrangement and you know
make some space for me to introduce
another chart here um so you can't do
some light layout and explore let's add
a time series chart and again my
automatic record count metric is just
going to show me the number of flights
over this almost 20 year time period and
one of the things we see is that there
are some months with missing data so no
data is without its data quality issues
there's also a lot of noise because
there's seasonal seasonal fluctuation
I'm really just interested in the long
term trend here I'm gonna drill up I
didn't even configure a hierarchy in
this case it just knows that this is a
date/time data type and so it added year
month and day for me I can just drill up
without any configuration that's month
and that's year automatic drill down now
you'll notice that it plummets in 2018
and that doesn't seem to make sense to
me because if I drove back down to month
I don't see it plummeting at the end of
2018 the thing is what's going on here
it looks like the data only goes up
until July August 2018 so I don't have
full data for 2018 look how easy this is
to filter this out I only want to look
at this by year and I want a drag year
up here and I'm gonna say okay 2018 has
partial data so let me just filter that
out I'm doing the opposite of what I did
before I don't want only 2018 I want
everything but 2018 I'll click apply and
I filtered out that year with partial
data just like that so that's the number
of flights that's been increasing over
the years be interesting to see what
other metrics I have in here so let's
see I'll go to my metric picture and I
think we've got some data on flight
delays so I've got yeah like departure
delay do you think that the average
departure delay has gone down or up over
the last year's few years how many
people think it's gone down that's
pretty sad how many people think it's
gone up
okay the vast majority of you okay so
let's drag departure delay and departure
delays have been going up for early
the last 17 years or so they've been
getting gradually worse from about six
minutes to 17 18 minutes in Atlanta last
year a couple years ago so is that trend
true everywhere though and again you'll
see the power of this cross filtering I
can explore my data with minimal to
little to no configuration
I noticed Seattle on here I live in
Seattle and so I do the commute the jet
commute from Seattle to some Seattle
people okay or person one person okay so
I can look at does this trend hold true
has the delays been increasing for
Seattle to San Francisco I just filtered
that and it hasn't thankfully so
thankfully for me I guess that flight
has been holding steady
what other metrics do I have in here so
I've got departure delay I can also add
arrival delay so look at the rival delay
alongside that and that actually has
been steady or if anything decreasing as
well other metrics I think I have a
metric in here about the actual elapsed
flight for time maybe that's also what I
care about how long is it gonna take me
to fly from Seattle to San Francisco I
mean this I wouldn't think would change
very much except it has a lot what's
interesting is this has gone up a lot
between 2004 and 2007 and then again
really skyrocketing the last couple of
years if the flights not delayed then
why would the actual time of the flight
be taking longer well I mean I guess
it's possible that they've just
scheduled the flight to take longer so I
actually have the scheduled elapsed time
of the flight and sure enough those are
correlated so they've actually just been
scheduling my flight from Seattle to San
Francisco to take longer and longer why
would they schedule a flight to take
longer busy airports okay what what
could that impact fuel the flying sort
is slower due to fuel yeah you take a
look at tax e time so taxing in and
taxiing out yes
so maybe the time is spent on the ground
and not in the air so I can search for
taxi the problem is as you just pointed
out yeah I guess there's there's taxi
out and there's taxi back in I'm
actually interested in the some of those
I don't have that but I can easily
create that by just creating a
calculated field and saying I want taxi
out
Plus taxi in and of course I can do
other calculations as well but just on
the fly taxi in click apply is that
trying to look familiar a little big
increase from 2004 to 2007 and and again
in the last couple years taxi time has
gone from 19 minutes to almost half an
hour
so is that trend holding across other
airports in the United States if I look
at Chicago it was getting better for a
long while until the last five years or
so that has been getting worse in New
York it's kind of always been bad over
half an hour but it looks like in 2007
and 2008 it was close to 45 minutes on
the ground in a flame so these are just
some of the insights that you can get by
visually exploring your data in this way
showed off new features of data studio
as well as of course the decor API
engine that was giving us the snappy
response throughout the whole thing
so I've analyzed my data but next I'm
gonna hand it over to Mary all right all
right so Ricardo went through some of
the analysis workflow but we know that
there's a kind of a next stage of making
sure that this is consumable for users
so I'm gonna hop back here real quick so
jumping back to our our heroine Ruth she
has four problems she wants to solve now
that she's gone through this analysis
stage one is that she needs to make sure
that that interactive experience
continued on for viewers so they can
continue to interact with the data once
she shares it out with them um to is she
wants to be tailored for the particular
audiences whether that's just leadership
or practitioners on the ground and then
lastly she's to be able to actually
distribute these reports in a really
efficient and effective manner so those
are the problems I want us to solve
let's go see how to do that
okay so we were let me find the right -
here we go
okay so Ricardo walked us through this
analysis this deep dive on San Francisco
I'm gonna actually take what he has here
and I have a report going on that I've
been spending some time on looking at
some of these same trends and I'm gonna
actually go over here what we have is
that report that I created so it's
looking at flights by carrier
cancellations arrival and departure
delays then
also have a San Francisco deep dive and
I'm ready to drop those charts that we
just created into our report so all I
did was say that analysis I copied those
charts and then I brought it in here so
I can continue to work with this data
and start sharing it out so I'm gonna
apply some light styling changes okay
actually looks pretty good let me drop
this down a little bit okay so the first
thing I want to solve here is that I
could share this out with my viewers as
is sure but I want them to still be able
to interact with this data so I can add
controls to the page that make that
really easy for our users so one is
Origin City name so they can quickly
select what origin of the flights taking
off from and I'm also gonna add one so
they can filter by carrier name so let
me carry your name perfect so what that
looks like here is I can come in and say
show me all the United flights do a
quick select and that's gonna update on
the fly cool yeah so one of the things
that I often find there then we often
see as well is that you share this
report out with people and then they
come back with questions like what does
this mean and am i interpreting this
correctly how do I use this report so
that's you have any tips for how to
solve that yes that's a common problem
or a challenge that we hear is how do I
educate users when they're looking at
this data so what I'm going to do in
this case is we have something called
URL embed that makes that easy to embed
other content directly into your report
so in this case we have flight data and
I it's looking at San Francisco in
particular so I actually found a YouTube
video and it gives an overview of the
San Francisco Airport annual report and
so I'm actually going to include this
directly into my into my report and so
users as they're interacting with the
data can come in and learn a little bit
more about San Francisco operations give
them some context for as they're
consuming this data and then lastly it's
pretty common that as you're going
through some analysis you're taking
notes you're finding some call-outs
about the schema I've put those all in
just a
quick dock with some information about
the data set some information about the
schema itself some delay codes and I'm
going to take that same approach here
and instead of having to send this over
in an email I would actually just embed
that directly into the report so I can
now interact with both the video I won't
play it for us it's a little dated and
this document that has some more context
on my analysis all right here it's a
pretty powerful so now that I have this
interactive viewing experience I've
tailored it so they can consume the data
right away I know I'm ready to actually
start distributing that data so we have
a couple different options based on the
audience number one is I can come in
here and just download this report we
know that a lot of people still operate
in PDF mode so we can quickly get a PDF
to download with them I can also just
share the link with them directly
so they can quickly go and consume this
online the download PDF feature is
definitely really useful but I think one
thing we find often is like people are
asking me to email them the updated
report every week so is there a way that
we can just automate that you set me up
for Cardo is perfect so we have email
delivery which delivers the report in
your inbox it's a really rich experience
I actually want to give you guys all a
little homework and go try this out
today it puts the report directly into
your inbox so in a lot of cases you can
consume that data right there sometimes
you might want to click through to learn
a little bit more it's also available in
PDF so you can make sure that if you
want your team to be seeing this every
Monday or every day you're looking at
this data you can make sure that this is
in front of them in a place where we
spend a lot of our time these days so
we've gone through the analysis with
ricardo as well as actually taking that
report making it into something that's
consumable but still interactive and
distributing it out we're gonna jump
back to Ruth's story and with that we're
gonna bring minhas up on the stage who's
gonna show us what's next for Ruth all
right all right thank you very high min
house cozy and one of the developer
advocates for data studio and we're
going to take you through the rest of
Ruth's story so Ruth has been doing very
well at her job she has set up this
whole entire data pipeline based on
bakery bi engine she has set up all
dashboards set up the PDF export people
are getting reports people are doing
running Alice's everything has been
going really well for root until
something really terrible happens root
gets promoted to be a manager so now
Ruth has a different set of problems
because she had solved all that issue
where people were emailing her about can
you write this sequel for me or can you
debug this sequel code for me but it
went from being that to people setting
up even setting up meetings with her and
people setting up emails saying that hey
my dashboard is broken can you fix it my
dashboard is running very slow can you
fix that one I've been getting this
quota error issue what is this about so
she started getting all these complaints
and she starts taking note of them and
she wants to solve this with her team so
the major problem she runs across is
again can we make all the dashboards
fast now in routes Department they were
using the BI engine to make things
faster however at this point all the
other departments in her organization
are not using the same BI engine
approach for example marketing has been
pulling in data from Google Analytics
Google Ads
Finance has been putting their data in
CSV files and in sheets a chair has set
up their own my cycle instance in the
basement in a server so all of those
reports need to be faster so what is the
solution that route came up with well
you obviously can migrate to the
bigquery BI engine you can take your
data put it in B engine and pull the
reports from there and if you think
about the spectrum where you have I want
really fast dashboards and I want my
data to be updated regularly bi engine
actually takes care of both of these
however if that's not an option for you
but then you can go the extract data way
which will let you make really fast
dashboards so let's look at ticket let's
take a look at how that works over here
I have a dashboard that is pulling in
live Twitter data from the Twitter API
for the Google data studio hashtag and
this is a Twitter data source if I view
this and then i refresh it you'll see
that it takes some time it will reach
into the connector it will pull the API
it will format the data so it takes some
time to update and refresh the dashboard
if we want to make the
faster what we could do is go back in
select the data source and use the
extract feature on it and to use the
extract feature what we will do is
select extract data as a new connector
and then so this is a new connector
extract lead off over on the left side I
will have all the data sources that have
created previously so I'll use the
Twitter data source I will add that to
the report I'll pick the fields that are
relevant for me so big screen name
Twitter text date retweet count and I'll
pull back the date as a date range as I
click this save and extract button what
data studio does is reaches into that
connector pulls in all the data and
saves it on GCS as a small bucket where
the oldest data is materialized as a
static source so add this back to the
report and as I look at the report I see
there's this new untitled data source
that the one that I just treated as a
material I see a source and if I view
this and I click on refresh you can see
it's very fast so you can take this data
source and then you can create new
charts tables with it and it'll remain
very fast
so that is one option the limitations of
extract data is that the data set is
limited to hundred megabytes and we're
working on a feature which will let you
automatically schedule updates to the
extract data so you can set up
scheduling and the data extract would
automatically get updated at a certain
interval but what if you want to work on
the other end of the spectrum where you
want really fresh data for your users as
a dashboard owner you can always refresh
the dashboard but if you want the dash
work to be updated for your users as
well then you need a different approach
and then route solution was basically to
use the new face feature of data
freshness this is available both for
bigquery and sheets where you can go
into the options for data source and
said set the interval by which the data
source should be updated for sheets it
will be between 15 minutes to 12 hours
and for bigquery it'll be between one
hour to 12 hours so this was Ruth's
first week as a manager the first week
goes by she goes home
so we can she comes back on Monday opens
her email and this is the first signal
she sees it's an email from the
compliance Department all of these
reports you are making and sharing with
people what are you doing about data
governance are you making sure that
everyone is viewing exactly the data
that they have access to we know that we
have a lot of data that can be shared
across organizations across the entire
organization but there are other
datasets that can be shared only for
specific people so people shouldn't be
viewing all the reports they should only
can't they should be able to view only
the stuff that they have access to for
this she only had an existing solution
which was of enforcing viewers
credentials for each data source in data
studio you can go into the data set
option and set the data source access
level to either owners or viewers owners
lets you view the data source based on
whoever created the dashboard or the
Riesz but viewers mix ensures that if
you're viewing the report your
credentials would get passed into the
data source and if you don't have access
to the data source you cannot view the
data for example let's say there is a
worksheet with all the HR information
about employees HR department has access
to it but the sales department does not
so if you create a dashboard from that
data source and then share that with
other people the HR employees will see
what they're supposed to see on the left
side but if someone has access to the
dashboard who is not a nature employee
not within their organization they'll
still be able to open the dashboard but
they'll just see that you don't have
access to this data because that
worksheet that sheet was not shared with
you so this is done at a complete entire
data set level Hey - can you talk us
through what we can do if we need their
security be administered on a row basis
that is a good question because this is
what we're showing right now is like an
entire data set basis but oftentimes
organizations would require row level
access for example in route steam there
are two analysts one of the analysts
work on the west coast's they focus
mostly on California and Oregon and
other Alice focuses on the DC metro area
the DC virginia and maryland so
the statist he has on flight she would
like to separate out this data so that
people can only see what they're had
what they have access to and to do that
if they wanted to they will want to
implement row-level security route was
trying to find ways what can she do so
there was this analyst in her team who
used to work as a developer long time
ago they have some familiarity with
JavaScript but they're not a full
full-blown developer they are not like a
coder so they looked into the data
Studios developer website and they
realize that they can get this done
using community connectors they can
implement a community connector and
enforce viewers friendships with it the
way it would work is basically over here
let's say we have a report this is the
report view for the analyst who is
viewing the data for West Coast so they
can only see California and Oregon data
and here all the cities for California
Oregon I'll take the exactly same report
copy the URL and I'll open it up for the
other analyst who has access to the West
Coast data East Coast data so I'll paste
in the exact same report URL I won't
change anything else
and as I access this report you'll see
that this person will not see the West
Coast data they'll see only the East
Coast data so you have Virginia and
Maryland so these are the exact two same
reports but over here based on who is
accessing the report you're filtering
the data for the same data source it's
the same table all the rules are getting
filtered based on who is viewing the
report and to do that all they have to
do all the analysts have to do is go
into the data studios developers website
figure out how this committee collectors
works we've made it much easier
previously you'd have to use the
bigquery connector using the REST API
but we've introduced a new feature
called advanced services that lets you
pass configuration directly from data
studio into bigquery so if you're
writing a connector the only thing you
need to pass is just a configuration
that I want data from this table this is
how you should filter it and these are
the access token which makes the code
very small the connector that I showed
you the dashboard the connector code for
that is this this is it it's only like a
probably a hundred lines of code
and most of it is just configuration
data there is no business logic involved
so anyone with minimal level of
understanding of JavaScript should be
able to implement this in a very short
time so that gets implemented a lot of
people in roots organization are now
using data studio they're creating
reports a new problem comes up it takes
a long time for people to get ramped up
if they have never used it as to you
before if they have never used bigquery
before once they start it takes them
some time to learn it so to go from just
data to a completed dashboard it takes
maybe days or hours so a dieter comes by
roots desk and ask hey can we make this
whole approach much faster can we maybe
implement templates so that an user can
come in start with the template and they
can get started just like that pretty
fast and since a lot of users will be
doing this we also need to keep this
under cost like we have to have cost
control and make sure the performance
does not get bogged down even though a
lot of people are using it so Ruth
remember that last year at the next
video she saw a similar solution which
was a chrome UX report it was a
connector created with data studio this
is what the connector looks like it's
you basically go in this connector has
about more than a terabyte of data about
five million different URLs you just put
in a URL and this is exactly the
workflow a normal user would complete
they go to this URL they put in their
configuration information I'll just type
in google.com click connect and this
pulls in the data from bigquery
configures it and then as I click create
report this lands me into a templated
report with my configured data so a
regular user that has that have like
previously no experience with bigquery
or data studio whatsoever can go from
just nothing to their configured
template that they can edit and share
with other people in just four clicks
this is something we already showed you
last year but we have made more
improvements from this so this is a
report for Google comm if we want to
change the configuration if you want to
see this for a different website what we
would have to do is
go back to the connector put in a new
configuration go through the flow again
and that would create us a new report so
you'd get new reports for every URL for
every website we tried it we try to make
this simpler so what we did was a
scalable report this is the exam same
report but when you enable the URL
parameters you can just go in and change
the configuration through the URL so
this is showing data for Wikipedia I can
just go in in the URL parameters I just
change this for Stack Overflow it's
still the same report but it will now
change the configuration call the
connector again fetch the new data cache
the new data and show you the
information for Stack Overflow in the
same dashboard so the viewers
credentials paired with this URL
parameter lets you do massive scalable
reporting you can just create one report
and roll it out to thousands of users
they will only see the information that
they have access to you can also take a
report and then pass configurations in
the URL and the user will end up seeing
different data based on what
configuration you are passing so this is
the configuration of the architecture of
the connector that we showed you last
year
so that gets solved people are now using
all of their internal data in the FA
they're creating Alice's they're
creating dashboards and now listen root
teams routes team comes up and says I
found something externally there's an
external data set that we think would be
really helpful it is not in within our
organization it is not on bigquery it is
not in our database but we'd like to
bring that in and use that with data
studio and this data set was on Kaggle
so how could we bring in cattle data
into data studio there was a solution
available because we launched the
integration between cattle and data
studio let's see an example for that
maybe I'll go in onto the cattle website
this is a flight data set on cattle
website and the good thing is if you log
on to the cattle website and navigate to
any cattle data set you'll have a little
button here that says open in and you
can click data studio
you can pick which file you want and
that will take you from the cattle
interface into data studio with the
connector configuration selected and
it'll pull in live data from cattle and
let you do that all the analysis in data
studio you can also take this data and
blend it with your own data now they
brought in the external data they March
it
everything has been going well route
gets more responsibilities the supply
chain analytics team has been merged
into roots team they have been doing a
really great job but in the supply chain
they have this prevalent practice of
using Sankey chart for a lot of their
analysis and that's the chart type that
is not natively available in data studio
so this is a new problem that route us
to stall but I have to make this chart
type available in data studio because my
team needs to use it so how work how
could they do that there is a new
feature available it is under Developer
Preview which is the community
visualization and here's an example of a
Sankey chart available in data studio
what you can do is create your own chart
using javascript you can use any popular
library that you want you can use d3 or
some other library create the chart user
API import that chart into Data studio
and then that chart will get rendered in
data studio and it will work with your
existing data pipeline that is available
in data studio it will work with all the
filters other chart types cross
filtering everything we will work out of
the box as it is there is a nice gallery
of community visualizations available
this is made by one of our partners
click inside this is showing small
multiples which is interactive
we have scatter chart which is another
interactive scatter chart where you can
do filtering you can exclude this one
you can add this back if you want more
information about how to use community
connectors you can go into our developer
site and check out the instructions
there now career visualizations are not
limited to only the stuff we have here
you can build your own chart for example
the one we built for the community viz
launched this is a chart that shows the
release notes of data studio over the
last few years for example in two
18 these are all the releases we had and
as we hover over things you can see that
we launched this feature in July where
do you become a part of the Google
marketing platform so if you have a
chart for a year for a chart if you know
JavaScript or have access to research
that can build you have a script charts
you can bring in your own chart and
render that in data studio now this
chart shows what we have done over the
last few years but to show you what
we're going to do over the next few
years
here's Ricardo all right thanks minhas
see I'll wrap us up really quickly you
want to get to your questions as well
for sure but I just want to talk a
little bit about how we think about the
investments that we're making in data
studio our goal really is to help you
make better decisions by helping you
along this entire workflow from how you
connect to your data how you make it
fast with things like bigquery BI engine
how you get it into the right forum how
you analyze it using the visual tools
that we have like filtering and sorting
and drill down today I showed drill down
in charts now we're starting you know to
extend that to pivot tables as well and
we want to work on other types of
interactivity that at analytic value as
well on the reporting front a
conditional formatting is something that
we've heard from a lot of people and
marién team are hard at work on that
feature distribution we showed scheduled
email today we're interested in other
types of distribution as well and so we
have investments in each one of these
areas there's also cross-cutting
investments
we're always investing in our developer
platform we showed community
visualizations community connectors
we're really just getting started with
those and so we envision a world where
there's lots and lots of community
visualizations that you can go and
choose from and build upon as well and
one of the areas where we heard a lot of
feedback is data studio started as it's
very very easy to use tool you it looks
a lot like Google Docs and Google slides
and the files get saved in your Google
Drive but what happens when somebody
leaves the company what happens when you
want shared ownership of things what if
you are a Google cloud customer and you
manage everything in GCP projects
wouldn't it be nice if you could store
your reports and your data models in GCP
projects what if you have Google Cloud
identities set up
then you have policies they're set up
what if you could hook into those things
so one of the things we're looking at
and working on is how can we bring more
enterprise administration capabilities
built on Google cloud platform to data
studio so stay tuned for that
just recapping some of the things that
we showed today these are all available
today they have either been just
launched very recently or they were
launched literally this morning drill
down is one of them scheduled email
delivery we launched earlier this year
sorting launch today as well the
bigquery BI engine of course launched
today if you want to stay on top of this
stuff support google.com slash data
studio we publish release notes every
week or so so stay tuned for all the
latest announcements
[Music]